para analizar lo que fue esta edición
del giro de Italia se encuentra con
nosotros Tatiana Rodríguez periodista
del diario aza Colombia bienvenida
Tatiana Gracias Luis Buenas noches Así
es primero vamos entonces a analizar un
poco lo que fue la el título de primos
roglis en este en esta competencia es el
justo ganador de la misma tomando en
consideración lo que venía realizando
gerin Thomas hasta la etapa número 20 y
también nos retiros que se vieron
forzados por casos de covid-19 pues Luis
yo creo que la historia tenía una deuda
con primos Robles y el esloveno sí que
supo cobrarla el día de ayer en esa
contrarreloj y vestirse con la camiseta
rosada del día de hoy en el paseo por
Roma había mucha decepción por la forma
como Los favoritos habían llegado a la
contrarreloj pero en ese adormecimiento
tal vez en ese cálculo extremo que
tuvieron y sobre todo en el desperdicio
de montaña que tuvieron durante todo el
giro creo en la figura que resaltó fue
la del esloveno la de primos roglish lo
que hizo en el capuchino esa etapa antes
de la de la segunda contrarreloj de la
competencia lo que hizo también los
movimientos en el monte bondone los
segundos que arañó también entre China y
Laredo creo que lo hacen un justo
ganador llegó con uno de los mejores
gregarios de la competencia con el
estadounidense secus además con un
equipo bastante fuerte Entonces yo creo
que sí es un justo ganador de la
competencia lo de geraint Thomas una
lástima verdaderamente del ciclista
británico pero en medio de ese cálculo
que siempre tiene lineos que para mí es
bastante extremo debieron también haber
programado y planificado un escenario
como el que sucedió ayer en la
contrarreloj haber pensado que tal vez
primos Robles iba a estar más fuerte y
le iba a sacar Y los segundos que
necesitaba para ser campeón
lastimosamente no lo hicieron durante
toda todo el giro fueron bastante
conservadores y creo que primos
aprovecho esto y se llevó de buena
manera el giro de Italia ahora por otro
lado Tatiana hablamos un poquito de una
carrera que siempre le ha venido a los
pedalistas latinoamericanos muy bien
como lo es este giro qué podemos decir
de la actuación de este año donde dos
colombianos precisamente consiguieron
dos victorias de etapa creo que lo de
Santiago buitrago y lo de INE Rubio fue
muy bueno hicieron un gran giro Santiago
siendo gregario de damiano caruso
poniéndolo en el cuarto lugar de la
general de la competencia al italiano
además ayudando también para que su
equipo se llevara la clasificación
general del giro de Italia la
clasificación por equipos y pues en esa
etapa de lavaredo que fue impresionante
lo que hizo Santiago buitrago lo de
einer fue un poco más difícil llegaba
como jefe de filas del Movistar Tuvo una
semana primera muy complicada muy
difícil en la que perdió tiempo
le tocó venir de atrás en las en la
segunda y en la tercera semana y lo hizo
bien De todas formas ganó esa etapa en
Crash Montana en ese Duelo recordado con
Jefferson Cepeda y tivot pinot y además
nos mostró una faceta que desconocíamos
de él que era la punta de velocidad como
ganó en esa etapa en territorio suizo lo
de Fernando Gaviria creo que podemos
analizarlo en tres dificultades que
tiene el embalador colombiano lo primero
es que ya no es el mismo Fernando de
antes sí ya le cuesta un poco más ya no
tiene la misma punta de velocidad que
tenía en años anteriores lo otro es que
no tiene equipo tampoco un equipo como
que tenga las características para
apoyarlo en lo que él necesita no lo
tiene y lo tercero es que cometió muchos
errores en cada embalaje se ubicó mal
comenzó antes el embalaje al embaldo de
Lejos envalo de cerca y siempre hubo una
equivocación para él y lo de Jefferson
Cepeda creo que se basó en en ayudar a
hukarty y también por el título de la
montaña para benjili pero creo que el
ecuatoriano lo hizo bien también ahora
por otro lado quisiéramos hablar de
marca bendice logra esta victoria de
etapa que amplía su registro en cuanto a
grandes vueltas pero también importante
lo que piensa hacer en el Tour de
Francia donde buscará romper ese récord
de Erick marcaba bendice es una leyenda
viviente del ciclismo y yo creo que
cualquier ciclista que tenga su palmarés
que a propósito Es bastante amplio más
de 150 victorias y cuatro títulos
mundiales tres en pista y uno en ruta
creo que cualquier ciclista que tuviera
ese palmarés estaría ya tranquilo para
retirarse no pero caben no caben quiere
romper ese récord del Tour de Francia
Son 34 etapas las que lo igualan con el
legendario de dimex y él quiere ganarse
esa etapa número 35 precisamente para
romper ese récord yo creo que lo que
mostró hoy en el final de esta etapa es
que todavía está vigente que todavía
tiene las piernas para poder hacerlo le
falta o le pasa mejor un poco lo de
Gaviria que no tiene equipo en el astana
tampoco tiene un lanzador pero tiene
esas ganas Y seguramente Es que le falta
solo una etapa entonces seguramente lo
va a lograr hoy veíamos como geraint
Thomas lo ayudó incluso a embalar tiene
también el cariño de todo el pelotón
Entonces yo creo que que seguramente sí
de el equipo decide llevarlo al Tour de
Francia que seguramente Así será va a
poder conseguir esa etapa Tatiana
Muchísimas gracias por todo este amplio
análisis sobre el giro de Italia a
ustedes Muchísimas gracias